this has been a long and challenging day
but at the end of it I'm pleased to have
received the backing of my colleagues in
tonight's ballot whilst I'm grateful for
that support a significant number of
colleagues did cast a votes against me
and I've listened to what they said
following this but ballots we now need
to get on with the job of delivering
brexit for the British people and
building a better future for this
country a brexit that delivers on the
vote that people gave that brings back
control of our money our borders and our
laws that protects jobs security and the
Union that brings the country back
together rather than entrenching
division that must start here in
Westminster with politicians on all
sides coming together and acting in the
national interest for my part I've heard
what the House of Commons said about the
Northern Ireland backstop and when I go
to the European Council tomorrow I will
be seeking legal and political
assurances that will wage the concerns
that members of parliament have on that
issue but while delivering brexit is
important we also need to focus on the
other issues that people feel are vital
to them that matter to them today today
the issues that we came into politics to
deal with building a stronger economy
delivering first-class public services
building the homes that families need we
owe it to the people who put us here to
put their priorities first so here is
our renewed mission delivering the
brexit that people voted for bringing
the country back together and building a
country that truly works for everyone